I'm going to start with you nilin
so this is a semi-autobiographical film
and could you tell us a little bit about
how much of your childhood is actually
rooted in this film because I understand
it was filmed in the town where you grew
up and your father was also a tea seller
uh yes I think it's uh my story as well
as my childhood friend whose name was
Muhammad Bhai who used to be
projectionist so it all it is quite a
lot of I mean both our story put
together
what became last film show and
especially in 2011 when I was visiting
my parents they told me I should go and
see him because uh he had just lost his
job as projectionist so when I met him
you know uh he was a third generator
projected operator and we both sort of
Sat by the street and drinking chai and
started talking about it and he told me
look what a world we have come to I
don't know how to read or write English
and I've been fired from my job and
projectors are becoming spoon and film
prints are becoming Bangles you know so
and uh so with that notion in my head
over the years family and friends used
to tell me that okay we are not
surprised you are a filmmaker because
there's a kid used to collect all the
junk and you know the glasses and match
boxes and so uh I think while traveling
back to the city I was on a five hour
ride on a bus and there was the Indian
wedding party with women wearing all the
Bangles like we see in the movie and I
had five of us to kill you know my mind
sort of drifted away that oh that person
might be wearing I don't know Robert De
Niro movie or a Bollywood star she is
not even aware you know all this you
know and I sort of went and wrote that
as a crazy concept uh and years later
you know I think uh it was going to be
10 years of disappearance of Celluloid
so I thought okay maybe it might be a
good time to tell this story
um and uh also because uh I didn't
wanted to make something Nostalgia or or
sentimental you know I had to find in
the angles which is optimistic and gives
hope and you know uh so that's where the
Bangles kind of saved me you know so yes
it is pretty much a lot of crazy thing I
did as a kid you know including stealing
reels and getting into trouble with cops
and and and most of the places you see
is where I grew up it's north west of
India in Gujarat
I'm going to jump to bhaven um bovin is
more comfortable speaking in Hindi so I
will translate the questions for you all
and the answers above and for you this
is your first film you've never acted
before haven't watched too many films
what was the most challenging for you
could be acting
foreign
so he was saying that um one of the most
challenging things for him actually was
the scene with the factory when he went
to go see the Celluloid and what was
happening to it and for him personally
it was just too hot and there were
filming near that area but it was just
extremely too hot for him
I'm asking him how did Nolan help him I
mean this is the first time he's working
with an actor too that is not trained
and he has no training as well in this
industry
foreign
[Laughter]
would help him out is by giving him
almonds and by the way if you don't know
almonds are a very common thing in the
South Asian culture our mothers feed it
to us to make sure our brain stays sharp
so it's a big commodity and then he
would bribe him I would say by saying if
you do the scene correctly you're gonna
get some chocolate so that is the
winning formula here
um Cyril I'm going to jump to you
because what's so interesting in
watching this film for me especially was
that your use of music because you were
having to kind of balance that out with
the Bollywood tunes that were already
being utilized in the film so for you as
far as composing I know you wanted to
come from a very Universal approach so
talk to us about your Creations here
so first of all we work since uh 30
years together with nalin we met a long
time ago but it seems to be yesterday
um so we always start with some tracks
and giving some direction and then we
decide to go in another Direction
almost every movies
um now this time the idea was to be
close to the history of Cinema
in uh somehow came
the experience of tarkovsky movies
especially stalker when the music is
coming from the film and
um and we uh we ended up being quite
influenced by artemiev who was a
composer of tarkovsky and this is this
is also why I'm using some synthetizer
but also some real instrument as well
but um the the idea of the music when we
work together is not to be specially
coming from India
but to create uh the inner feeling of
each character
and to reflect it on the audience which
is uh with the idea of of being
Universal as much as possible
thank you
you know on that on that topic dear I'm
going to jump to you and because we're
talking about Regional too right so
normally when we hear of Indian Cinema
we're familiar with the Hindi language
people are familiar with Bollywood but
this film is done in Gujarat which is in
a region of India not a place that
people commonly know of so how
challenging was it for you to decide
that you want to place this film here
was it a risk fill me actually in this
part of India
um yeah you know I think with it's one
of the things that attracted me most to
the film and to nullen's work
um is that I you know we grew up
watching Bollywood and Hollywood films
and Bollywood films specifically have a
tendency to be slightly over the top uh
you know a mashup of genres action dance
and while that's great for what it is I
was longing to watch something that was
more authentic to where I come from and
I come from the same region that the
film is shot in
um and I you know I felt that there were
so many vibrant stories that could have
been told but that were just missing so
that when nalin eventually you know
wrote the script and and said it where
it said I felt like there was no better
place for it to be yes from a
perspective of of of of risk it was
risky
um essentially you know in India if you
don't have what nalin calls the three
s's the star the streamer uh or the
studio it becomes extremely difficult to
find an audience
um but I think you know with nalin's
conviction
um we were able to you know create
something that organically found an
audience and a theatrical audience at
that
um and I think that's something that
that was we discussed uh when we were
making the film it was about 2000 you
know 18 19 when you know when we started
the idea germinated to actually make it
a movie
um and the streaming services had come
and taken over you know most of people's
lives and viewing patterns and there was
less and less people going to the cinema
um and I think that's one of the reasons
that nullin sort of pushed himself to
write the story as well because
um and and for me why it was so personal
for me because I grew up going to the
cinema and just when I decided I wanted
to make films no one was going to the
cinema anymore so it for me it was a
perfect movie
um to sort of represent that magic that
I fell in love with the sort of wonder
that the movies gave me when I was young
and
um so when we eventually made the film
and we premiered here at Tribeca uh in
the US and we want an audience award
Runners up it was great it was just
after the pandemic we weren't sure what
was going to happen you know every
Festival was going online every film was
getting sold directly to a streamer but
I think nalin and me decided that we'll
wait but we'll wait for a theatrical
audience
um and we got really lucky that
um and I wouldn't take credit for that I
would say it's all null in his previous
work and this works specifically that
got us incredible major Distributors
worldwide we have you know the film has
opened in cinemas in theaters in Spain
in Germany in Israel in Taiwan in India
in Sweden and Norway in Singapore uh
it's going to come out in Japan with
shochiku which was the studio that did
all the uh Kuru Sava and you know ozu
films
um Medusa in Italy is Distributing it in
cinemas you have Samuel Goldwyn films in
the US so I feel like
for whatever's left to come with the
film you know we're excited for
whatever's left to come but already the
journey in a post-pandemic world
specifically for an Indian film or what
what would eventually become foreign
language or World Cinema it's been it's
been incredible
congratulations on that worldwide
distribution now Lynn for you and
especially for some people who may or
may not be familiar with Bollywood
Cinema with Indian Cinema you were very
strategic in the films and the shots
that you picked to highlight in this
film could you talk a little bit about
that
I think I have always tried to find
first of all the stories I fall in love
with you know so even when I did my
first feature samsara I would say little
did the score and it was picked up by
Miramax you know and uh that was about
19 years ago and they were really
insisting that like even India should
send as Oscar entry and you know and but
we released it worldwide uh ultimately I
think you know for me it's really
important like in samsara which is very
different than angry Indian goddesses or
Valley of flowers I also documentaries
so I've done something called Faith
connection it's always to find what is
the DNA of the story you know and once I
understand the nature and DNA of the
story that dictates the Cinematic
grammar you know so I'm not that kind of
author or director who will impose same
style or all kind of stories uh and I
often fall in love with different type
of stories it can be action it can be
drama it can be love story so here
pretty much the entire cinematic grammar
was found because of the story to be
authentic to be you know to go back to
the Innocence to find the Simplicity the
organic life which existed in this
region uh so yeah that was the ultimate
aim that how can we be as real uh as
possible
um as bhavin will tell you that why do
people like you can ask him why do
people like the film he has a good
theory about it which could be the
closing what I think yes we have to wrap
up here so I'm going to ask him real
quick too yeah
good afternoon
so yet theme factors is
okay so there are three facts to this
film why people will enjoy it they're
going to laugh
they're going to cry and then they're
going to get hungry and eat and that is
what's going to resonate with people all
right well thank you so much again
have a beautiful evening and a wonderful
weekend thank you
[Applause]